Paul Ryan was at Success Academy charter
school in Harlem New York earlier this
week and as he was leaving he was
hilariously booed and people chanted
healthcare for all not just Paul as well
as fu and there were many of those fu
chants the entire Trump Care American
Health Care Act Obamacare repeal Fiasco
is an ever-growing Fiasco truly here's
video from independent video journalist
sandy Beckham and not a friend in the
crowd for Paul Paul Ryan here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how did Paul Ryan keep that bizarre
smile on his face the entire time as an
entire city block is booing him he comes
out and waves maybe he misheard the
booing and profanity as cheers yeah or
maybe he was being sarcastic I guess
just get in the car and go yeah and Paul
Ryan the thing about Paul Ryan in his
relationship to health care policy is
that he's so obviously involved directly
in this totally abortive bill but he's
also a huge hypocrite he relied on
Social Security benefits as a teen when
his father passed away arguably
government welfare programs are
responsible for keeping Paul Ryan on his
feet helping him to pay for college
getting him to where he is today he's
worked in the public sector for decades
having his salary paid by taxpayer
dollars yet at any opportunity he wants
to take away systematically any Social
Welfare dollars that he can from average
people and if Trump and pence get
impeached you know who our president is
Pat Paul Ryan Paul Ryan that's exactly
right yeah I mean with a country of 300
million people you can find a crowd of
people who are going to boo any
particular policy or short ition but the
thing is here it's not the exception
it's the rule because their health care
bill is pulling anywhere from 17 to 38
percent yes and Paul Ryan's is in charge
of a Congress that has a 20 percent
approval rating on that note we'll the
AHCA
aah a call it what you will will it take
down Republicans in the midterms there's
actually a risk here and it's pretty
clear that more reasonable House
Republicans get it despite voting in
favor of this bill they all had the
sense to decline the MSNBC invitation on
joy Reid's program to explain why they
voted for it
it's so unpopular that it's not worth
appearing in public to defend it and
Senate Republicans seem to be closer to
reality on this it's going to be hard to
find something that both Senate
Republicans will agree with along with
the most extreme House Republicans
that's what it'll take to pass this and
I don't know if it'll happen and of
course the Congressional Budget Office
hasn't yet assessed this and many of
those congressmen when they give the
interview say they didn't read it
yes I'm sure Paul Ryan's going to be
against this because in 2000
9 he said I don't think we should pass
bills when we haven't read them and we
don't know what they cost I'm glad you
brought that up because earlier in the
week we said it was sort of set up so
that members of Congress members of the
house wouldn't have time to read the
health care bill I later found out is is
this true it's only a 66 page bill yeah
but there was amendments added on to it
66 pages actually isn't a lot to read in
three days so I kind of want to amend my
prior comments about it when I sit down
and read a nonfiction book if I read for
an hour depending on the book it's about
a minute per page yeah or a little more
right you're talking about 45 to 60
pages an hour if you have three days and
20% of the American economy is connected
to health care you actually do have the
time and should have the motivation to
read 66 pages maybe have the amendment
some are summarized by staff but you can
read 66 pages and of course this isn't
light reading because there's a lot of
legal e style text in there you're
making a policy proposal even then three
minutes per page you can still do it you
know what I mean
yeah do you think Pat that the tax plan
and maybe even the Obamacare repeal and
replacement will be delayed because of
the James Comey fiasco and it'll just
slow down everything that's going on I
think Democrats will use that as a
reason to slow those things down but
ultimately they'll get to the floor
would maybe Republicans also focus on
other things I don't know I got a lot of
emails from people yesterday saying the
the tax plan is definitely slowing down
and maybe even the aah a will see that
Komi fiasco is not going away anytime
soon today's episode of the David Pakman
show is made possible in part by Warby
Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker recently
did the right thing
and ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription
into I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS